[Music]
hey everybody and we are back yeah this
is a good one that i can't remember who
um who uh requested this one or or at
least suggested it to me it may have
been louie i was talking about
you know
watching cocaine cowboys
and uh we went jenny and i went ahead
and watched this when did we well what
day did we see this probably about a
week ago no it wasn't that long ago it
was just like a couple uh it was just a
couple days ago a couple days ago all
right it seemed like a long time ago now
it was a good series
yeah well what's something i didn't know
so this was actually made by um a dude
like a documentarian named billy corbin
now prior to this he had actually made
three
sort of stand-alone documentaries yeah
um also called cocaine cowboys like i
think the first one came back like way
like came out way back in 2006. so i
haven't seen any of those but this is
the new one on netflix yeah this is the
new one on netflix which is like a six
part series that one the the um the ones
that he did before didn't really cover
this tale uh you know these two guys in
particular it kind of covered some other
other guys [ __ ] that was going on too
but i haven't seen those but i've heard
those are really good so you know the i
guess the dude's from miami and that's
kind of his specialty for doing the
documentary so he's the one that did
this one yeah you can see it on netflix
right now it's it's it's a great series
it's about these these two guys who
ended up just becoming the damn kings
of miami this series is uh [ __ ]
florida as [ __ ] it is yeah this is like
uh this is
you know this is these are these two
guys are kind of like the real scarface
you know scarface was something out of
[ __ ] hollywood this is the real deal
this is how they really lived
this is uh who the guys really were and
they were just young dudes in their 20s
they were second generation cuban
cuban americans
and uh
cocaine was illegal but it wasn't that
illegal back then you you know what i
mean you had to
you had to really be abusing uh uh the
[ __ ] cocaine to get serious serious
time for it when they started you know
um i mean california almost treated it
almost like it was legal back at around
this time in the 70s but it wasn't until
the war on drugs hit that it became that
that you could do serious time for it
but
these two guys
plug in they saw
cocaine is their way into the american
dream
but it worked for a while they got for a
while they got [ __ ] huge they did it
for a long time they had
a very
organized little
company uh between them and their
friends and they had a lot of fun in the
clubs around here built a lot of [ __ ]
and did a whole bunch of [ __ ] boat
racing speed boat racing and they were
all over the [ __ ] television
they were televising their speed boat
races and everything and these dudes
were making like millions and millions
of dollars a month yeah with needing to
have jobs
nobody asked any questions
and this movie
prior to this
on other shows you know i was making you
know we live in florida i live in
orlando and i'd be joking around saying
that the miami skyline was built on
cocaine i wasn't joking this is about
that era yeah all right that building
that fell down a couple of months back
was like
from this era it was being built with
this kind of drug money all right
and uh it was just another time man
well i mean they there were so much they
brought in so much drug money that it
also i mean you know i guess that's bad
but it's like in a way it like really
helps the economy
yeah
yeah i mean because you got to think
it's not just like you know it's all
these people with money suddenly and
it's like but they you know they need
groceries and cars and [ __ ] like that so
it's like it kind of they jump started
the economy yeah that caused the growth
of
florida
it's not as bad as it was evidently but
who knows because everybody was involved
elected officials were involved [ __ ]
everybody well they kind of go into this
i really liked this series because even
though it's about drug dealers and they
did some really really shady [ __ ] uh up
to and including maybe allegedly having
a bunch of people bumped off yeah um
but that said i like that this kind of
this series kind of like toes the line
between it's actually like really
entertaining yeah it's funny and and
funny and goes into a lot of
the [ __ ] that was going on behind the
scenes like with them because they got
caught a few times but they somehow like
most of the time managed to wangle their
way out yeah they'd be in prison and all
of a sudden they'd find out that they
got released who released those we don't
know
they just got yeah because they had all
these like connections they could bribe
any policemen they could do whatever
they had but then yeah but then like on
the other side you almost kind of like
want to admire them because it was just
two guys one of whom was like pretty
smart and the other one like a lot of
the friends and stuff said not all that
bright just dumb guy but
they're just kind of like these dudes
and they just they just started selling
coke like back in the late 70s like as a
side hustle essentially and then when
the guy that was kind of like the big
boss that they were kind of like you
know because they were small time um
what was his name jorge valdez i think
they interview him on there too and he's
a character he's like super funny yeah
yeah this is nothing he's he's out of it
now he's like a preacher now what makes
this series so special is that the guys
they're talking about are in this
documentary talking about what it was
like to do other than the two main guys
willie falcone and uh sal magluta most
of them are out of prison now will yeah
falcone and the other guy what's his
name willie with sal maglito
sal and falcone or willy salad willie
they're locked up because they were
involved in murders they're not getting
they're never getting out because yeah
well because what ended up happening
yeah because the rest of them i i think
that jorge valdez like i said who was
sort of like the boss and he ended up
going to prison like in eight 1980 or
something like that yeah and that was
like when william sal sort of took over
his operation and they ended up bringing
in what like 75 tons of coke so even
like cocaine that was like sold in new
york and stuff probably came from
it built in new york and la also they
were fueling all that yeah it was it was
a [ __ ] time yeah and they these dudes
were
they were [ __ ] big i mean you know
what i mean they
the bee gees played at their weddings
that kind of [ __ ] they know oh my god
real rockstar
they tell all those stories
um
yeah
they're on espn all the time racing
[ __ ] cigars
but they were speedboats they were
speedboat [ __ ] champions on espn and
well didn't isn't that how one of them
got caught yeah it was one time because
on the espn and like a sheriff was like
hey i know that guy right that's not the
most wanted players he's on [ __ ] espn
yeah it's funny because they didn't see
themselves as criminals they just see
themselves as good guys they were in
their 20s having a good time yeah yeah
we're just selling this white stuff yeah
snorted
[Laughter]
and it was they didn't even have jobs
but they were making millions and
millions of dollars
they took care of everybody they knew
they were kind of like a robin hood type
people you know they just paid everybody
they'd give the cops millions of dollars
uh or try to bribe the cops let me go
and i'll give you everything i got in
the truck you can have it i know i'll
tell you where a warehouse is where
there's billions of dollars well i mean
what ended up happening like what kind
of got them into trouble like i said was
that
you know when they finally got busted in
what like the early 90s or something
like that
um
they found out later they actually got
acquitted
and then when uh you know they started
looking into it more they figured out
that they had actually paid off like
three of the jurors and also they had
done this little thing where they got
their defense attorneys to essentially
publish a list of
uh
potential witnesses like in prison
magazines and stuff like that and then
mysteriously hmm a bunch of those people
turned up dead yeah um you know a couple
of them survived because one of the
dudes i think was they tried to get him
with a car bomb uh and actually his wife
was driving the car but she wasn't hurt
she was all right but um some of the
people absolutely did turn up dead yeah
what's funny about these guys is that
they were really well liked
um
they grew up with guys that ended up
being cops too they went to high school
with guys that ended up being cops um
they
they went on for probably 15 or 16 years
before they ever
[ __ ] uh resorted to violence they
didn't kill anybody until very late in
their careers they believed that
violence just attracted a lot of
unwanted attention and they were they
were right
as long as it was everything was being
done between friends and nobody killed
anybody
and they spent a lot of money and spread
money around they kind of evaded
detection
nobody really wanted them it wasn't
until much later
and when they did want them it was for
little stuff yeah it was the one that
they that they wanted to put him in jail
for some do this passport or having fake
ids
yeah well they wanted to put him in i
mean they the thing about it in this you
know they i kind of feel like they knew
that these guys were big time drug
dealers were drug kingpins essentially
but there wasn't enough evidence to hold
them on those charges so they always try
to like find other little things like oh
this guy had like a whole bunch of
different like fake drivers licenses so
they're gonna try and hold just so they
can hold you in prison until they can
find evidence of like bigger [ __ ] so
that's essentially they're pretty good
at keeping their fingerprints off of
things um
it was weird they just kind of made
friends with the main drug dealer
who was there before him this
other guy was much older than them and
then
they just sucked and said [ __ ] it they
had a friend who was a pilot and they
just decided to buy an airplane and they
just started bringing it in themselves
through an airplane and they were just
taking it to an island off the coast of
florida and then just running it from
that island
uh to florida in speed boats
uh that's why they were such good i
guess speed boat racers they had a bunch
of speed boats they're like hey we could
just use this first
ton of damn cocaine in the damn
boat you know
going 100 miles an hour is uh but it's
an interesting series camp guy said he
just looked at netflix and said it's the
number one uh
it's at the top of the suggestion list
yeah because it just it just premiered
like a week or two ago it's good got
good editing got a good little theme you
know theme song in between each
pitbull song yeah
and what's great is uh
all the all the guys in this drug cartel
are all free they're here in florida
yeah because it was a long time
they're all out of jail now except the
two main guys and that was because they
they did some murders
but the other guys didn't
and
the their right-hand man was a guy who's
much younger than them he [ __ ] worked
out you can see he kind of [ __ ] did
some roids got a real hot [ __ ] blonde
cuban wife and they even had her
they even gave her a television series
well she was on real housewives of miami
yeah real housewives wasn't she on there
i think she would yeah talking about how
her husband is no longer involved in
that [ __ ] that they're living although
his that was uh his name was his uh
because everybody has nicknames on the
show um his nickname was peggy p e g way
yeah i think his real name is pedro yeah
but um pedro is a real good-looking guy
too he looks like a male male but the
thing about it though is that after they
filmed this series like he went to
prison again for some other [ __ ] yeah
yeah oh you know they're doing stuff
they're doing stuff but so it's like
even though he's on there like talking
about you know not really want to do it
anymore i understand it though yeah they
have all the friends they have the
background and the and that's really
where they came from and um
they got addicted to living like that
i mean i could see how that would happen
it's like you just get really used to
really used to having a million dollars
having millions of dollars not have to
worry about anything and like living the
high life everybody loves you you can go
into nightclubs and everybody's kissing
your ass and you get just by the whole
nightclub
and uh
you know [ __ ] they were they had a
whole bunch of concubines and
prostitutes that followed them around
and the wives tolerated it because they
just give the wife here here's a hundred
thousand dollars babe go shopping it'd
be all right you know she could
basically do what she wanted and they
everybody just kind of did whatever they
wanted
you know it was a scene
another one of my favorite characters on
here other than uh jorge valdez who was
who was a trip but also was sal's uh
girlfriend yeah what was her marilyn i
think was her name was marilyn yeah oh
my gosh well she kept the books yeah she
had like the ledger together yeah and
she was kind of like held [ __ ] together
like when he was in prison and she is
hilarious [ __ ] real hilarious she is
delightful
fbi's got everything tapped and
it just shows uh how kind of far ahead
they were you know they were talking to
colombia and talking to places in cuba
and [ __ ] on [ __ ] what was that island
that they kept talking to where they
were staging the
it was the drop point oh yeah i can't
remember now anyway they had to have a
whole system of [ __ ] shortwave radios
so they can communicate
clandestinely yeah
with all these damn drug depots they're
speaking in code and [ __ ] like it was a
sophisticated
homegrown operation by guys that were
high school dropouts
yeah when you think about it we'll see
like i said those just go to show
there's lots of different kinds of
intelligence yeah
they were they were uh
geniuses at what they were doing and uh
a lot of it was social skill and then
just imagination they would imagine some
[ __ ] and make it they had enough money
to make it happen
yeah and i mean it helped too that i
mean because the thing about it
is that obviously if you get caught like
and you you are arrested for you know
drug trafficking right yeah um obviously
you're not allowed to use any of the
money that you earn drugs drug
trafficking
yeah
however
somehow i don't think anyone's entirely
sure how but these two guys
figured out somehow that
like how to get out how to access their
money because they must have had some
like for like somewhere because they
froze all their assets all in cash yeah
so i kind of feel like because they paid
for like this amazing like defense team
yeah everything well don't know the
lawyers basically the series kind of
hints to the not in a wink that the
lawyers found ways that they could
accept the money yeah okay so lawyers
helped them launder that money it's what
it was yeah what theirs they just like i
said i don't think any of them wanted to
say that outright but i think that was
the implementation that goes to show you
it's not just florida it's just way
courts are when those lawyers see those
dollar signs oh no no we need that
client look at all that money yeah we
can't let the cops get that that money
will vanish we got to channel that
through us we'll pay taxes on it it'll
all be spread around so they know
exactly what they're doing yeah and a
bunch of cops were on the take too cops
were all on the take they were helping
because the cops were like uh he got
pulled over one time and and the cops
pulled him over looking looked at him
and he went and he goes you know who i
am and it's like yeah he goes just go on
the trump just take what's uh in the
trunk and what was in the truck was i
think what was it a half a million
dollars
yeah i can't remember that yeah a box a
half a million dollars in a bunch of
coke and just take what's in charge i
was doing business with nick house one
okay thank you
so you know this is not florida's not
these are florida men
florida is [ __ ] staffed by florida
man
yeah it's not the same world as it is in
other states
it's i don't know i kind of feel like
this is like that everywhere i think
this kind of [ __ ] goes on everywhere
the whole southern half of florida is
central america it really is it's an
upscale central america and that's not a
bad thing it's just that the rules
they're different
um
and who controls it's different that's
that's cuban territory
basically cubans
or ethnic style cuban people descendants
of the spanish empire have been there
before the united states ever existed
all right so people think of these
somehow immigrants from central america
no they were here before there was an
america that was spain yeah yeah now
that's right and they this this is
this is uh how they do things
um
and i'm okay with it they're
they're doing good well like i said i
don't
you know you guys know i'm kind of like
more of an advocate of what i don't give
a [ __ ]
of legalizing drugs uh just across the
board yeah because i think it'll make
[ __ ] generally less dangerous yes
illegalizing it was actually a power and
a money grab they could make a lot more
money off of it if it was illegal that's
why they did it
so like i said i'm not you know i'm not
saying that these two guys i'm not
saying they're like heroic or anything
like that because they did have people
killed they were entertaining them and
that's not cool but this was like
actually a really entertaining very
entertaining documentary about them yeah
yeah camp guy said amazing how fast you
can run out of money as well yeah
exactly tell me about it exactly um
he says my wife and i can barely keep a
five-figure balance in our regular
everyday checking account again yeah
yeah it's well it's just like little
little [ __ ] you know well that's what i
was saying they were addicted to that
lifestyle um
you know
to them
okay well they talked about
they had a bunch of safe houses all
around in their territory just places
where they could go places where they
could stash money cash drugs or a place
where they could crash or a place they
could take some girl real quick
and uh and the crews you know it wasn't
just
the two main guys it was also all their
whole crew could just go to all these
little safe houses everywhere
and they would forget money in these
safe houses some of those safe houses
hidden up in the attics was millions of
dollars millions
and they'd forget all about it yeah can
you imagine just like misplacing a
couple million dollars yeah they had
more money than they could spend and it
was it was difficult to launder the drug
money so it would just pile up and pile
up
and they didn't own anything they had to
buy things through other people's names
which is hard which is one of the
reasons why it was hard to catch them
because they on paper they didn't really
own anything everything was owned by
in-laws and relatives and
yeah and and they and those people kind
of had jobs a lot of them so they could
kind of
kind of
work out a
thinly veiled [ __ ]
camouflage that yeah this is we own this
but then there was just big
boxes and bundles and bundles of [ __ ]
cash everywhere
yeah
um
there was one story where didn't they
one
they lost a st safe house or they sold a
state safe house and forgot that up in
the at it was about a million dollars
and a new owner found it
remember that one oh yeah wasn't there
one two where they tore up the floor and
there was like a safe under the floor
and there was a whole bunch of money in
there and then yeah the one guy i forgot
which one it was was it luis
he was taking a shower he was somewhere
else taking a shower and his mom went
through his room this is in the early
days
went through his closet they tried to
move a big box and the box ripped open
and it was like uh
was it a million and a half dollars in
his closet and he's and he's a teenager
basically
unemployed he's got about a million
dollars in the closet and then he took
him a while he had to explain that
how do you explain that you know
yeah i mean there's really no reason
that a teenager it's like if i was that
mom i'd be like you're a drug dealer
aren't you i mean there's really no
other yeah where the [ __ ] else would you
have gotten that
you know what i mean grantham's hammer
says is coke big in the goth party scene
no no no uh like do people snort lines
of blow and the bathroom stalls at
mannequins honestly i don't really think
cocaine never really never really seemed
uh all that big no
um it was only for that was only for
very rich people yeah i feel like that
was more an 80s yuppie drug i guess
people still do it nowadays you just
don't really hear that much about it i
think most of it gets most of it either
goes up the noses of very rich people or
it gets converted into crack cocaine and
that's just in the hood
yeah and you never really see that
um
what you see here would be things like
ecstasy maybe uh yeah i kind of feel
like that's it's more that type of thing
yeah
mdma
stuff like that um yeah well like more
like
psychedelics
yeah it really does seem like that's a
lot more widespread at least around here
at least you know among people we know
yeah um you know unless they're doing a
bunch of [ __ ] and not saying anything
weed is the most common you'll see lots
it is yeah there's tons and tons of that
yeah you can walk down downtown and
somebody walk by just whiffs weed smell
it's it's technically still illegal in
florida but i don't really think it's
being that enforced they don't yeah they
don't really care about them to do much
about it florida doesn't really in the
end doesn't give a [ __ ]
now if you had an entire car truck full
of it or big bag of it and they found
yeah you're gonna get trouble
get in yeah i mean intent to distribute
that's a whole other thing right uh
oracle said absinthe you don't see that
much either honestly um
absinthe isn't that's
it's almost kind of like well yeah but
i'm just saying that uh
alcohol yeah they do like i think
mannequins i think he does have some of
it there
but it's that's almost kind of more like
a special occasion yeah type of thing i
feel like it's just
i remember the herbal [ __ ] drink i
remember back in the day like when we
were at venue 13 i remember they had
like an absent party that was like
sponsored by lucid yeah which i don't
even know is around anymore i don't know
it was good that was good stuff though
but um it was just yeah i'm not a big
absinthe fan honestly it's like sambuca
it's too set yeah i don't really like
that
and that's not the way that's not the
way um evidently absent really tasted
absinthe was issued to like french
troops as water purification
and they kind of got a taste for it in
the napoleonic wars
and and other colonial wars that were
going on and they were mixing it with
water and sugar and weird [ __ ] like that
there was really nothing to it it's just
kind of like a health drink
and then there's all this stuff about oh
well it'll get you high or make it
hallucinate that was the wine industry
that that claimed that
they were losing ground to absence
companies yeah so they wanted to say
that it was like some kind of the wine
industry
paid for black propaganda or black press
in the french newspapers that absinthe
was dangerous but it wasn't it was
i mean it's just like chartreuse yeah
it's just it's alcohol yeah yeah i have
like i have a couple of books back there
about like the history of absinthe it's
actually like really really fascinating
and around kind of about the whole like
culture surrounding it as well yeah like
yeah you know my absence might have been
dangerous because the same dudes that
were drinking abstinence we're also
[ __ ] drinking a lot of them and
[ __ ] doing things like [ __ ]
shooting morphine i i kind of feel like
that's probably yeah so it's like don't
don't blame the absolutely it wasn't the
absolute they might have had to do with
the damn morphine that they were taking
and the [ __ ] cocaine that they were
drinking
yeah i i kind of feel like that was
probably more of a problem than like
exactly the same place
yeah and it's just like funny that well
like you said i you know the the whole
thing about you know green fairy and
hallucinating and stuff like that that
was mostly uh the wine industry that
initially came up with that trying to
make absence seem like like you said it
was dangerous or it was only like drunk
by degenerates or something like that
because they were losing market share
yeah because there was a time when
absence was like massively massively
popular yeah it was putting out it was
putting out the went the french wine
companies that had been around for a
[ __ ] 100 years and they were huge
because the french [ __ ] drank wine
like crazy and that was a huge industry
and they just and they had been there
for a long time and they had their
fingers in the in the damn
legal system and everything you know so
to protect the wine companies they went
after absence but there's nothing
special about absinthe not really nope
and somebody's asked about jagermeister
same [ __ ] there's nothing special about
that
it's just alcohol
with herbal flavors in it yeah that's
all it is
oracle says a friend of mine who's a
novelist drinks absinthe occasionally
but she admits it's part of her
victorian fetish
i like all the imagery surrounding it
you know like i said i even designed
like a board game
called the green hour that was kind of
like about all of that like all the old
absinthe bars like back repairs and
stuff back in the day so i like all the
cultural [ __ ] surrounding it but i don't
really
i don't really like the taste of it
particularly though i don't i don't like
that anise the flavor
evidently that wasn't in the original
one well yeah it's just buttery it had a
buttery which i had yeah i would like
that better some people say it was more
like a chartreuse flavor
yeah which you know i i could do that
but like i said i'm not real into only
copies of it survive there was a um and
it's all just based upon rumor what it
tasted like there were no it was a
proprietary
uh recipe like coca-cola
and anybody can make a cola
but was that the original coca-cola no
the original coca-cola doesn't even
taste like coca-cola today
there's the recipes out there from the
1800s people have done it they go oh
yeah that's good that's not a coca-cola
yeah yeah you can make it the original
recipe is out there
but it wouldn't it wouldn't be
marketable
last avenger 85 says didn't van gogh cut
his ear off by drinking too much
absinthe no um no no i honestly he had
other problems yeah i mean yeah he was a
drunk yeah and he drank abscess too but
like i said and he had mental problems
that's that's come from the [ __ ]
french propaganda of the time man yeah i
don't think it was that just the absence
wasn't the ability and honestly
morphine honestly if you drank enough of
anything you do stupid [ __ ] yeah so it
doesn't have to be absent it could be
anything those same people were [ __ ]
doing things like injecting morphine and
drinking cocaine that had been dissolved
in [ __ ]
wine
they did all kinds of drugs people think
that along that there were no drugs that
drugs are a new phenomenon [ __ ] no
the 1800s was [ __ ] just drug addled
they i'm like surprised this people
lived as long as they did i mean they
didn't live as long as nowadays but i
would have thought they'd drop dead
before they were 30. you could just go
to a store about what they were doing
you could just go to a store and buy a
gigantic jar of cocaine for like nothing
well it was legal it's illegal you could
go buy a big [ __ ] big bottle of
[ __ ] logan which is morphine
yeah basically and you could drink it or
you could inject it you could do
whatever you wanted but they even they
drank a lot of them and that was
supposed to be just cough medicine like
a cure all
if you felt bad drink this you'll feel
better they sat around drinking that
[ __ ] all day long
[Laughter]
i don't really get like i said coca-cola
had cocaine in it that's why that's why
pepsi pepped you up
so people have a [ __ ] very skewed
victorian concept seriously i read a
book a while back too that's all about
the history of like sodas yeah and
almost all of them were started i mean
the whole thing of like soft drinks what
they all started out as like medicines
yeah so a lot of them did have
drugs in them yeah like back in the day
what got people [ __ ] sober really
and what got europe off of taking all
their [ __ ] morphine and london and
cocaine and
all that alcohol
what got them to kind of stop that was
coffee
because coffee came and that was a safe
alternative because the water was boiled
yeah
they drank alcohol and drank these drugs
because they were clean you couldn't
drink water out of the tap it was
[ __ ] contaminated back then yeah
so you had to drink something that was
water like a liquid like water adjacent
and uh so they were mostly high or drunk
because of what they were drinking the
safe [ __ ] was all some kind of drug
but then coffee came coffee and tea yeah
from like the middle east yeah and uh
those were safer alternatives that
wouldn't really [ __ ] you up
so kind of like the whole
this whole concept of not being
constantly high or drunk is a product of
the the advent of cars yeah that's like
yeah and [ __ ] and t before then
everybody was [ __ ] up all the time
yeah it was very well i can't really
blame them because it's like you know if
you live back then you probably wouldn't
be [ __ ] up all the time too they lived
in poverty most of them so it never
didn't even get much to eat horrible
conditions yeah it's just kind of like
what else are you gonna do you could get
like booze and [ __ ] for really cheap or
drugs a poor person back then nutrition
was a couple pints of beer and a piece
of bread yup you were lucky if it had
butter on it yep that's they lived off
that yep
yeah most people did yeah that's why
they looked [ __ ] up the poor people
didn't have any [ __ ] muscle mass or
anything didn't live long teeth fell out
early
really bad nutrition
and uh their only way to [ __ ] kind of
stay you know make themselves feel
decent after all that [ __ ]
deprivation is just like a drink lauding
them
drink a bunch of cocaine yeah
yeah and
in coca-cola or pepsi or something yeah
yeah cause i you know like i said i have
a couple histories of absinthe and soda
and stuff like that because that's like
something that's really interesting i
also have like two or three books that
are a history of coffee and it kind of
goes into that too because they started
drinking coffee and then they started to
get a little more intellectual
yeah because like i said there's a whole
coffee house culture that's where a lot
of like the enlightenment kind of shakes
yeah i'm drinking coffee reading and
talking and [ __ ] talking about
politics yeah we gotta stop yeah because
everyone wants to ever wasn't drunk yet
we gotta start fixing this first time
ever right
and that had to do with a lot of solving
a lot oh my god i'm sober yeah this
feels really strange maybe we ought to
build clean water systems in the cities
so people don't have to [ __ ]
drink water that has rotten eels in it
right
exactly you turn on a spit spigot and
[ __ ] rotten eel parts had come out
because it was just infested with eels
yeah all kinds of [ __ ] people don't
realize yeah they [ __ ] parts of the
water systems of these major sit
european cities that get [ __ ] clogged
up and taste imputred the whole [ __ ]
half the damn city complaining about it
they try to figure out what the problem
is and it'd just be a big rotten ball of
hundreds of [ __ ] eels clogging up a
main line somewhere yeah
because it was just infested with eels
oracle said actually that reminds me of
something i heard about chinese railroad
railroad workers they were less prone to
waterborne disease because they rarely
drank unboiled water because they
usually had like tea or tea if they
couldn't get tea that they would just
drink like hot water like boiled water
yeah
yeah well you know you i was talking to
sod you know he's in saudi arabia you
know and being being from an islamic
background they're very suspicious of
alcohol use
and i just had to explain to him i said
without alcohol there would have been no
europe because the population would have
[ __ ] plummeted down to nothing
because there was just no clean water
supply not in the cities it would have
gone back to it it would have been an
apocalypse it had gone right back to the
rural
life
uh
for popular to have population density
but the way it was back then and we're
talking you know the periods of 13 13 to
15 to 1600s around that time you had to
have alcohol especially distilled
alcohol was the best
because they would just get a bunch of
[ __ ] filthy water out of the damn tap
pour some whiskey in it
to try to purify it they drink that
look at that
that was their that was their water
sanitation was just
pouring
better than nothing
pouring whiskey into the into the filthy
water so you can drink it
with rotten eel juice in it and sewage
because yeah people had no problem with
throwing a bucket of piss into the
[ __ ] water supply that would be all
right it's just water
yeah it really seemed like i said if you
guys haven't read there's a really great
book i have it back there on the shelves
it's called the ghost map
and it's about them discovering
uh
what caused waterborne illnesses and
like you said prior to the really the
end of the 1800s they didn't really have
any concept of let's not like just
[ __ ] water in the water and have like
just these big pools of [ __ ] and piss
in this plate and then like have the
water yeah spig it right by it so it's
like leaching into the water table and
it's like everyone's like gee i wonder
why everyone's getting sick right
it's like now it's like duh but back
then they didn't really no water for
purification and when they got when one
doctor like kind of in the it was
he was in london and he came and said
you know maybe there's these little like
microorganisms he didn't call him that
obviously but he's like maybe there's
little things in the water that we can't
see they're making us sick um and
everyone's everyone thought he was crazy
because everybody thought that it was
the air yeah that it was like stinky air
stinky air was like making you sick
miasma and that they called it uh-huh
yeah yeah well i mean it stands to
reason because you know yeah if the if
the if you you know the water's [ __ ]
up it's gonna stink and yeah everybody's
getting sick but so everybody thinks
that the stink is causing the sick but
it's not it's actually the water but
because you can't see
you know you can't see the
microorganisms that are in the water
yeah then you know they they just
thought he was like making it up
it says i think our modern water and
health departments are some of them some
of the most hard to imagine wonders of
the first world yeah
yeah exactly
you take clean water
for granted that wasn't there that was
that's a
recent
invention yeah is to be in a city and
have clean water
yeah and not like not even
european cities you don't even really
have to think about it and honestly now
like if we have a storm or something and
it like messes up the water pipes and
you have to boil your water for like a
couple days people freak the [ __ ] out
yeah and i'm just like holy crap it's
like
you know they'll fix it it's not like
the [ __ ] middle ages where it's like
the water is just full of poop yeah jeez
calm down
that's not that big
all right so i think that probably
covers it with cocaine cowboys huh yeah
definitely if you're interested in south
florida at all um like i said i haven't
seen his because he made three
documentaries about this like prior
going back to 2006 which were kind of
like i don't think they were standalone
i think it was like a series but he made
them like a few years apart uh but yeah
so this is like a six
a six part series
so it's about five percent exactly
another thing is good about this series
it shows people
not only in america but also a lot of
people in america don't even realize
this but it shows people outside the
united states
how local american government really is
yeah when you think of [ __ ] the
american government you're thinking of
washington dc washington d.c has nothing
to do with what's going on
on the ground in most of these places in
the united states
you watch this and you will see that
really this was a miami thing
yeah and miami was kind of a small town
when this was happening
yeah i mean it's a massive city but
the scene where it was taking place was
like
and you would and you just see how local
government actually is
government is a local phenomenon if you
have a lot of friends in your local
government and your local police and you
have enough money and you've greased
enough palms you can evade even federal
law enforcement
yeah and that's fbi was after him
you know and it took him a long time to
get him both of them yeah they were
after a lot
and they actually had a good survival
strategy
no they didn't want any of this [ __ ]
public murder or wholesale slaughter
that some of the other drug groups were
doing
so the priority was to catch the violent
ones
yeah so all the federal guys really they
knew about these falcone and the other
dudes
but they were kind of
they weren't killing anybody so the
priority was on the smaller groups well
and rightfully rightfully so trying to
they had to mop them up first well
they'd mop them up and they'd quickly
replaced by some other violet guys so
they were constantly in the background
as kind of being the low priority target
even they were making all the money even
though they were bringing in billions
they were the ones that were making all
the money yeah
actually they even said like the
wikipedia page i think of theirs uh said
that um 75 tons of cocaine but the the
guys on there like jorge valdez and
stuff he's like it was more like 175
tons he's like i don't think they got it
all or they didn't like know how much it
was so he's like saying he thought it
was like way more than the than the
estimate yeah but they're colorful
characters and uh they're there in that
series and it's funny to hear their
sides of the stories talking about you
know being a drug dealer
it's a very stressful life you're
constantly worried
we had money but you know they kind of
the money's not all that we had
unlimited money but but you're
constantly worrying you know
that's the thing about it it's like
because i kind of like every time i
watch these kind of series yeah i'm
always just kind of like man maybe maybe
i should be a drug dealer but then i was
just kind of
look at all the money but the thing you
never get at night sleep yeah you would
never you would constantly be worried
when you're doing illegal [ __ ] like that
yeah i'm sure like having billions of
dollars is nice but you can't ever
really enjoy it i mean and it's not just
that the law might come down on your ass
it's that like somebody else might
[ __ ] pop you another thing that was
funny is that is just the unlimited
greed because
they had been doing this for 10 years at
one point they could have just got out
and one of the lieutenants was like dude
you have a hundred and you have over a
hundred million dollars and he goes why
don't you just walk away he says he
hadn't even been arrested you just
walked in you just walk away from it now
and he thought about it for a second he
goes when i hit a billion i will when i
hit a billion see that's what gets you
in trouble yeah when i hit a billion
i'll walk away i mean if i had 100
million dollars i'd be like okay i'm
and i hadn't gotten caught yeah and
nobody had bumped me off or anything i'd
be like okay i'm awesome i'm just gonna
go
retire to some island somewhere and
change my name and just live out the
rest of my life they had dozens of
[ __ ] houses dozens of safe houses
all right dozens of safe houses several
mansions a [ __ ] ton of boats a whole
fleet of [ __ ] luxury cars
and a hundred million dollars in cash
and he and he could have just walked
away
and and just gone quietly into the night
he and his he and his brother
and they said we'll do that when we hit
a billion
as if a hundred billion is but i think a
hundred or million isn't 100 million
doesn't seem like a lot when you're
spending a million a month i guess
i guess i can't but that must be like
they're spending a million a month in
clubs
yeah i mean really
you think after a while you just kind of
get sick of doing that and you're like
all right well i'm just gonna save some
money now yeah i don't know but yeah but
it's really entertaining though
it was i had heard of these two guys
because like i said i'm from you know i
grew up in florida my whole life um i'm
not from miami but uh you know you kind
of heard about it secondhand uh but i
didn't know like kind of all the [ __ ]
about
the [ __ ] they were doing like [ __ ]
with the jury and all that other kind of
stuff so that was like so it's like
really really interesting and it was
kind of like i said it's
it's kind of interesting how they
and a little bit inspiring how just
these two guys just kind of works their
way up like that like i said it's the
american dream in some [ __ ] up kind of
way but then like how they evaded the
police but like i said it you know it's
just like a really interesting yeah
they're they're behind bars for life now
though they should have quit where they
were ahead
well and uh wasn't one of the i think um
wasn't willy's brother cousin something
like that like wasn't he on the lam for
like 25 years and they only just
recently caught him like a year or two
ago yeah but the dumb thing was that he
didn't go anyplace he was like still
yeah
he was like in kissimmee or something
which is like right by disney world
another funny thing is that they would
be wanted for these charges now most of
these offenses they probably would have
only done 18 months to five years but
they just did not want to go to jail
but they wouldn't run either they would
stay right here in florida yes
but like i said you can go anywhere you
could go anywhere you could go somewhere
that doesn't have extradition they
didn't like to leave florida they really
didn't like to south florida was their
homeland and they did not that was their
ethnic homeland and they did not want to
leave yeah well because like i said when
they finally tracked down willie's i
can't i can't remember if it was his
brother he was like involved too but he
was on like the most wanted list for
like 20 25 years something like that he
was on the lamb and when they ended up
arresting him he was just right he was
right down the street from here he was
like he was like 20 miles from here in
kissimmee yeah just living in a regular
ass house yeah and they just never found
him after all that time just like they
finally busted him yeah so see the
series is pretty good yeah it is really
good all right so uh we'll be back
tomorrow talking about another uh series
actually we'll probably do that other
series tomorrow if we finish it tonight
because we found another really good
series on netflix i don't know how long
it's been on there but it's uh really
really good yeah the japanese one yeah
yeah yeah what's it called it's called
battle for japan the age of samurai the
age of samurai battle in japan check
that out
yeah kind of like it's about the history
of the [ __ ] the samurai and how they
how this samurai daimyo [ __ ] warlords
were fighting each other and all the
major names and his reenactments really
good [ __ ] great great um
uh animations in between yeah it's
beautiful looking really cool
really cool it's kind of like game of
thrones but a documentary
yeah it's pretty cool so yeah we'll
probably talk about that tomorrow i
think we have i think that's also six
parts um what i think we watched like
the first four first season yeah and uh
so we need to watch like the last two
tonight and then we'll talk about it
tomorrow but that's really good too so
uh yeah so have a good rest of your
weekend everybody and uh we'll see you
guys again tomorrow